Oh Oh it's a weird nerve right here with
my ring
I heard of my whole head is taking a
close look at my face is right
oh wow there's some weird point here my
whole hand is like numb right now okay
I'm playing start believe nation know
what's up I'm gonna just hold my hand
here for a while
we are just over one week from the first
tour stop it's in Pittsburgh it's crazy
I've got some new prizes to give away I
think I gotta put it down and get some
blood flow in here I don't know
Holly Kevin okay well I shake out my
hand
neither's gonna give you the update of
what she's been working on for the past
week since the last video for the past
week what's the result where are we I
got none nothing done the past week
because of the holidays and the kids are
here just like a chaos so nothing was
done nothing okay great
I can't feel my finger this finger I
can't feel it I can't I can barely feel
that I feel that but like here like okay
just just relax
yeah we'll see you know it guys we'll
see how it gets you know you never know
what's gonna happen in the video don't
have your rings on when you clap guys
just don't clap like that yeah I imagine
don't sound like that in the session
okay what are you working on before we
launch your first phase we got the EOB
we're gonna maybe set out we got we got
the speaker we got the microphone I'm
working on my playlist I'm super pumped
by all the I've been spending some some
good time over the past week really
honing the content and probably by
Thursday
IG this is coming on Thursday I'll be
finished and really excited I go through
these moments this is obviously a big
tour it's a big it's a big part of my
new plan it's its comfort zone breaking
for me and I go through moments where
like oh my god scary you know I'm going
to
you gotta do 23 cities and this is crazy
people are showing up but I don't
disappoint people and then I look over
the material and what we're covering and
like I'm so pumped by this is like this
is gonna be so amazing truly
life-changing for a lot of people will
end up coming up the activities
especially with the group if you're when
you're around other people too who are
trying to go off and do something
amazing it's just it's a different vibe
like when you around people who there's
yes it's great to be talking and seeing
you hear from the camera and your
computer screen and your phone but when
it's face to face it's a different
energy and when you're rather the people
who are trying to push on their dreams
too it's it's a totally different energy
and we're gonna use that energy to get
you to act we're gonna use that energy
to get you to move and I look at the
exercise and my practices and go for my
head and sometimes out loud and it's I'm
just blown away by how awesome it's
gonna be legit
so I haven't moments of doubt and then I
have these amazing moments of when I
look at the content that this is gonna
be it's maybe I it's gonna blow people's
faces up I'm so pumped for it I'm so
nice it's you you will be impressed
Nina's give this is gonna make the asset
test you will be impressed
Nina's sat in on you sat in on have you
seen me speak live I don't think so
actually if you've never seen me speak
live yeah Wow
but you sat in on coaching sessions kind
of you said and unlike meetups inside
whatever you've sat in on this is gonna
be you came up what would say what was
the event that you went to take oh that
was really good was it my interviews in
the car on the tractor on the drive down
the New York you see the nearly
interviews and you're impressed this
this is gonna be I'm gonna blow Nina's
face off is gonna be you're gonna be you
will be the asset test I think Ian's
gonna cry I'm gonna cry
yeah yeah I'm pretty sure tears will
come even if you say that I will not cry
no I don't think so I think you'll just
be sober around you won't be able to
help it yeah not just from me but from
the experiences that people have from
them breaking through and their [ __ ]
them shut man
Mitsy no you'll you'll you'll hear it
and you're gonna cry 23 cities you're
gonna cry each one yeah I'm I'm 90% sure
that you're gonna be crying in each city
this is very exciting I got a new
challenge excited okay guys we got
prizes to announce I mean guys there's a
whole bunch of prizes on top of just the
awesome content so what are you coming
for the tour we're doing 23 cities we're
helping you break through your limiting
beliefs helping you take action helping
you set a schedule for success helping
you stop worrying about other people's
expectations and judgments of you
helping you and not let yourself against
that judgment helping you move from
self-doubt to self belief and and doing
work in the event not just get motivated
that go home you're by yourself
we're making progress in event you can
be doing work in the event we're giving
a bunch a ton of prizes away over
$100,000 in prizes from coaching
sessions with guys like Grant Cardone
and Tom bill you and dave meltzer then
lock to coming to my workshop in May for
free six months of mentoring with me
coffee shop meetups for the people who
come from far away yeah everybody gets a
free coaching session with Lilia $200
value flex calendar whole bunch of stuff
on top of the three hours of Awesomeness
with how much is a ticket for bucks it's
a great value guys you gotta get it you
gotta get it anyway we're launching two
more prizes these are the last two I
think president we're gonna be
announcing on top of everything else
that we're doing so the first off is
Louis houses legacy program guys in
Louis he he has school of greatness
it's a great podcast YouTube channel has
been a friend to channel for a long time
he has a legacy course $2,000 value it's
closed right now but when he opens it up
we're gonna be giving away a ticket and
that's helping you build your legacy
bill draw like this and start making
money from your ideas and he watched you
through his process of how to do it
so he's letting somebody in from the
tour so somebody buys it one tour ticket
randomly will give access to the course
$2,000 value and the other one is Tony
Robbins is
bring us two tickets to his next UPW
unleash the power within not the March 1
because that's coming up too soon yeah
but the one after he hasn't he hasn't
finalized the dates it'll probably be
New Jersey or Chicago I think there's
two other places where he doesn't he
does it somewhere in California and then
like New Jersey Chicago area so to one
of those in late 2019 so we'll get two
tickets for somebody and we just don't
know the exact date or location oh we
don't get one take person though I
wanted to take it for the couple one
person gets two tickets so one winner
will get to take it so you get to bring
somebody with you bring your wife or a
husband no it was a great experience for
us both to go to bring a friend that
went with mark Drager friend of the
channel yeah recently great experience
too or you can give it away to somebody
else but the ID yeah yeah that's good
yeah it's a good gift anyway so so those
are the two exercise that we're giving
away those are those are all the prizes
I think so far in the tour but most
importantly is going to come and have a
life-changing experience you get to meet
Nina come on back surprise that's the
best prize I'm so pumped I can't explain
how excited I am to you guys do this so
let's get to some of the comments if you
want to leave a comment on this video
Nina and I will look at an answer next
video some of the comments were linked
up 23 days in 90 cities is really
massive you know the 90 days 23 cities
doesn't seem very big for me well like
just the speaking thing is a speaking
thing is that's the pressure the idea of
spending 90 days and going on the road
when I first came with that idea
the scary thing for me was more like you
wouldn't your job and if you want to do
it for me going on the road for many
days didn't feel like a big commitment
even though a lot of people think it's a
huge commitment
I don't know through for me like my
agents freaking out saying what's such a
big deal okay doesn't feel like a big
deal but now doing paid speaking gigs in
each city now that's the pressure doing
like just going to the cities and coffee
shop meetup is is easy zero fear is zero
concern but now doing a paid speaking
gig I'm feeling the pressure to bring in
just insane value
my biggest viewers disappointing people
letting them down and so I pretty much
never do because I over deliver so much
but if it feels massive then then great
like go do something on your own right
part of the tour the idea is to also
we're off doing this thing what are you
doing you know how do you how can you
get inspired by it you go off to do your
thing and risk failure and risk you know
end up working out and and risk whatever
fear you have in front of you to go off
and chase your big dream town so thank
you lenka and hopefully we'll see you in
one of the cities oh she wrote 23 days
and 90 cities that would think I
actually could not would be made this
mistake two people said 23 days 90
cities you're doing you doing more than
know just I guess four cities a day or
is what 92 so yeah four cities a day
would be sane yeah yeah we're not doing
that we'd have to like holograph like
teleport to inner cities okay next
awesome twenty three days of fun times
starts should be good
ninety days to finally join in Phoenix
February 6 so expect me looking forward
to a Clifford never it's been a long
time supported the channel so excited to
meet you there in Phoenix Clifford
what's what are you most looking forward
to said fun times when you most looking
forward to on the tour I don't see you
[Music]
you're gonna cry mr. Betts
okay Christine ash I don't see any in
Florida would love to wane all because
of you truly being viable solution to
this world I don't see any in Florida
what do you think Nina go the head of
your convenience this is this is being
like burned that the people's brains put
your goals ahead of your convenience it
will not be convenient for you to
accomplish your goals and so this is
this is a good test if you want to come
then you come you find a way to come and
when I come to Florida the closest is
probably
No no houses yeah no we're going further
south than that you just got to go a
little wet oh I don't know we have
people that we met up in New York
they're coming from Florida - mm a D
yeah we have somebody coming from
Florida to Cincinnati like this is not
any way since add that that is someone
who's gonna win yeah that's someone's
gonna win and I almost want people to go
out of state just because yeah and then
the School of Rock sorry she's coming
from Texas there were not going to Texas
don't don't
you can't wait for something that come
to you or any of your goals you can't
wait for it to come to you you've got to
go chases down and it's not just me it's
anything that's on your list you can't
wait it's not gonna come to you you
can't wait you have to go off and chase
it down yeah if you want something you
go for it you go for it
you go for it and that's that's how you
build the self-respect and the
self-esteem and momentum where most
people never hit the news resolutions
because they wait for it to be
convenient and it never will be
and that's how you lose so everybody in
Florida I want to see you come out to
one of the events will you be doing
alive in this event no there'll be no
live of this event this is an intimate
experience this is it's not just the
content
it's the experience it's not just
learning a strategy it's us doing work
together like I'm gonna be doing the
work with you to help you get to where
you need to go and that's not something
that you can live stream properly so
we're gonna be doing videos of it some
of it will be released some of it won't
be but there will be no live stream come
to the lab event period next tarus I
watched a video titled don't make
decisions from fear where you sat with
the young kid and was taking a semester
off of college and trying to decide if
you should take one your job I'd love to
be the position to get some advice like
that and use that time with me as
content well today man we will dry you
he will tell you I will tell you and
Nina will cry come to the event I make
it happen you know what's the secret
arts this make it happen okay Cara did
you not see my tweet Nina
what sweet I don't have twitter mmm you
may want to talk that mean about my
tweet I already have my days off and
it's a four-hour drive for me ah I love
this you gonna win the prize maybe yeah
so Weber comes to the furthest away the
two people come from the first away to
get a coffee shop meet up with me bonus
two hours one or two days after yeah so
Charles got a good chance here but I
don't know why I don't know how you're
tweeting that need I could have Twitter
yeah I used but awesome Kara looking
forward to meeting you whatever city
you're coming to me a team ever do guys
know South Florida date thanks for all
you give to us another Floridian watch
come on Florida
come on Florida we want to see you come
on out show the Florida hustle goals
ahead inconvenience 2019 let's go
Tiffany so excited to see your
conference see you March 31st looking
forward to Tiffany where we merge city
first Roy
your manager no Minnesota no it's not
Minnesota yeah I think it's Minnesota
are you sure is that your final answer
final people I want you know IKEA well
pretty close market 27 like you should
have a we should have a skill testing
question for Nina in each video to
manager see how much you remember okay J
and coaching technologies great stuff
I'm gonna Nina you'll be awesome my
friend keep up the great work believe
inspiration nation are you coming
Ian isn't in we love we love this girl
okay get at you Tess I hope to see you
at the Troy Oh
Nina's gonna Terry did this one boy oh
is it
oh you like that you look at it hmm well
yeah that's why I hope to see you in
Detroit yeah that's a boy yeah I will
see you in this joy hope is not a
strategy let's make it happen get a
chick test we're excited
Lenny Nugent y'all are adorable what do
you think I'm not doing just you what
about the dykes that's they're sleeping
that third see we can't see the like see
what I hope one of them up he's sleeping
he wanted to come up won't listen as we
sat down so we're leaving the docks at
3:00 - uh spare me the hardest part SS I
have got to get that t-shirt click on
the expression on my homepage in the
circle potential expression you can find
the t-shirts and hoodies and all that
stuff yeah and if you come to the tour
we'll do a selfie together with the
t-shirt if you bring a man's book you
can assign it that's true - that's true
- love the idea and energy from growth
mindset thank you for the love this is
this is what we're giving people lots of
energy on the tour Leonard I want to
grow and want your bonus - thanks
come on - the tour is like a cartoon
character Boise decision come out to the
tour and we should have that as every
telling or something no or like we
should save it and then and then
whenever somebody asks a question like
we can play that die that sound we need
to put a little jingle behind it it
saying any creative entrepreneurs up
there who want to take that sound cliff
I mean I put a little song and I did
know that would be amazing
I would like that and I will share it
and then Don James Sam you say awesome
Evan awesome it is awesome pumped we've
got we've got just over a week before we
leave Pittsburgh the first stop and then
moving on to the rest of the tour I'm
just I'm just I'm just a bundle of
excitement and energy we can do this
video next week it'll be oh my god
so it is crazy it's almost hitting me
it's starting to hit me I have moments
where it's hitting me I'm moments make
basically a panic that's like it's
starting soon it's hitting me because we
on the keto diet and I just figured out
what to eat we're not fully on the keto
diet but it's close
that's not as stressful as going off and
changing lives
yeah making Mina cry in each city now I
know it doesn't matter it's gonna hit
you so hard you gonna cry for sure no I
mean my skin is very sexy
listen it's not what's company's when
I'm on stage doing the thing when I'm at
the front you will be impressed but you
won't cry you're gonna be like oh yeah
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
be like that's some sexy stuff happy for
sure but when people share their stories
and and then what they're doing to
change it and when they start acting on
it and like this is the life-changing
moment this event is the moment that
that moves their life forward that's
when you're gonna cry I'm gonna get
emotional but you're gonna you're gonna
full-on because the fact let's let's
play some tissue box today believe
believe Kleenex
yeah leave necks with tissues anyway I'm
starting to feel the the politicans
weekend feels like shopkins so believe
pins napkins
do you want to blow your nose with the
napkin I guess you can't it's kind of
rough it started starting to creep in I
have moments of panic and then I'm
review this is this is it I have a
moment of panic and then I look over the
notes of what I'm gonna be talking about
and practice like this is amazing I
can't wait what can I want to start
right now and then I look at it go
panicked look over this is amazing that
came with the start let's say right now
I don't even know what's the contact I
just thought it up I don't know what
you're gonna come you're gonna see
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
make some changes to it's gonna happen
and then you're gonna see people stars
you've macwrite that's the bed we should
take odds odds that Nina cries every
city and odds Nina cries once you've
seen zero for the whole thing
oh yeah no there's no way there's no way
she's gonna happen is for sure it's it's
okay guys leave us your comments ask
your questions about the tour we'll
answer it on next week's video thank you
for the support the momentum is amazing
I'm so pumped to meet you I'm so pumped
to help you let's make this mean
something to you and let's make this be
your next turning point I'm excited look
final message to Nina come on to the
tour the link is right there next to us
you can click on that get your ticket
continue to believe and we'll see you
there